pour ces enfants les billets les ballons
sont bel et bien rangé aujourd'hui
rendez-vous avec trousses cahiers livres
d'exercices et doit lever des cm1 cm2
nous sommes à l'école primaire isidore
pierre-louis du lorrain des révisions du
cp à la 3e
c'est pas évident sébastien enfants à
réviser à la maison si n'a pas mobilisé
depuis vraiment les bases avec eux donc
avec j'ai commencé l'alphabet il est
donc en egypte constat dressé au teint
former les lettres de façon latérale en
v1 est paré pour les chiffres donc
vraiment commencer par la baisse dans le
cadre du contrat local d'accompagnement
à la scolarité effectivement cela se
passe toute l'année du cp à la 3e
alors donc long du ce de ce nouveau
dispositif qui le clin d'oeil sur la
rentrée nous avons des enfants du
contrat local d'accompagnement à la
scolarité
nous avons aussi d'autres enfants des
enfants des communes voisines ont des
enfants qui nomme qui ne mangent pas aux
classes mais qui accepte de faire des
révisions scolaires
donc c'est vraiment de dispositifs qui
sont qui sont distants dont 20 euros les
enfants sont pris en charge toutes les
matinées de 8h à 12h des enfants
volontaires une quarantaine au total
toutes les bonnes choses ont donc une
fin c'est toujours bon de viser sûr
qu'on a fait l'année passée beaucoup ces
petits cours sont très bien pour se
remettre en tête tous les cons donc moi
je dis que c'est bénéfique
j'ai des difficultés en matière forcé et
puis c'est tout et c'est la vision ça
cela s'améliore
je suis mieux maintenant j'y passe en 5e
une école qui va reprendre une activité
normale le 4 septembre prochain avec
environ 130 inscrits